There's 2 cases here; so let's say the graph does have a clique the size of m,
then what will happen is the following.
So it contains exactly 1 vertex
that corresponds to a variable in that clause,
and what we also know is
because we constructed the graph this way,
that we can not have 2 vertices connected here in this graph
where there's a conflict, so what we can not have in this graph, for example
is 1 vertex that represent not x2
and another vertex that represents x2,
because we avoided this in the construction
but this directly shows us how we can
satisfy this Boolean formula here,
so if we have a not x2 here, we just set it to 0
so we could just set this one to false,
so that not x2 becomes true,
then this clause here is satisfied
and also this one over here would be satisfied.
And x1--that's a separate variable,
so we can set it as we want,
and we could set this one to false.
So we have x2
and we can set that to false so not x2 becomes true.
So that becomes true,
that one becomes true,
that one here is false.
Over here, we have not x2 as well,
so there's no conflict here.
x1--we haven't yet talked about x1,
but can just do the same thing; we can set x1 to false,
so the whole thing not x1 becomes true.
We have set it to false,
and we haven't even looked at x3,
but all of the clauses are already satisfied,
and that's actually the cool thing to notice here.
x3 is also not contained in the clique,
so the vertices in the clique tell you
how to set the variables
so that the Boolean formula can be satisfied.
So what if this graph here does not have a clique of size m?
Well in this case, it means that
we have 1 clause group
which is not contained in the clique
and if we have 1 clause group that is not contained in the clique,
this means that there's no vertex
in the clause group
that has connections to all of the other vertices in the smaller clique
that we're looking for,
and that means, due to the way we constructed the graph,
that every vertex
has a conflict with
another vertex in the clique
so if there's no large clique,
this means that every assignment
of true and false of the variables will lead to a conflict
such that at least 1 of the clauses
can not be satisfied.
So then the Boolean formula does not have a satisfying assignment.
So now that we have this reduction,
we know that clique is
NP complete,
which of course makes Bob a little unhappy.
So now what about vertex independent set?
Are those problems NP complete
or are we not sure yet?